A recommendation we give
developers from MercadoLibre as friends
of this event, is that they put all their efforts
into the execution and work capacity
... persistence. Some times we think that an
idea is everything. An idea, indeed, is important
however, 90%, specially in a startup, its execution.
To be really persistent
and work several hours to make something happen!
Google gives you really interesting tools for developers
Both, for mobile developers that can use the
Android suite, and for those into backend
with the cloud tools, from Google App Engine
to Prediction API or Big Query
what is really interesting is that Google gives
you free tools for small developer groups
That offers an excellent perspective for startups
that need to start with low costs, and world-class tools
The awesome thing we, developers in the region, have
is that we're used to scarcity
we're used to do things without the whole context
nor the elements that developers in the world have
that is a huge advantage when faced with
creating a new startup and to compete
because with very little, sometimes we do
what others won't even try
We invite everyone to participate in the event
I give the Developer Bus a plus one!